welcome to another sadler's stories i've
indulged several times in the past in
telling stories about cats who i spent a
lot of time with who are very important
to me who i got close with and who have
unfortunately
all died and who i sometimes miss
especially sassy who i was the closest
with and i've told you about sassy and
her sister teensy i've told you about
little boy and little girl whose
mother gave them to me when they were
kittens along with their brother and
sister who i gave to other people and
now it's time to talk about two other
cats that were very important for me and
who were part of
a household that included human beings
and cats and who also liked playing with
dogs from time to time and those are mew
and monkey
mew was a stray kitten and monkey was a
stray cat both of which were from
carbondale mew was found abandoned on
the
southern illinois university carbondale
campus out in the woods
and
monkey lived in the trailer park and was
probably somebody's pet
at one time so
this is all connected with the the story
of um
at that time my my girlfriend in
graduate school who i i married and then
subsequently divorced got an annulment
from but had two kids with lived uh in
indiana with as well as carbondale for
quite some time and um also you know
it's connected with the the land and the
my kids themselves because they grew up
with
mew and and monkey so
mew was found first she was a kitten and
as i mentioned was abandoned she was
wandering around crying and mew was kind
of unusual she was a female i forget
exactly what they call it but the golden
kinds of cats where it's yellowish and
brown mostly
uh boys but occasionally you do find a
female like that and my my girlfriend at
the time took in mew in part because she
had an older cat named smokey who her
father
had dumped on her essentially her father
had retired
with his his new wife um they were they
were you know getting an rv they sold
off their their house and stuff in
tennessee and they were going to go out
to montana and plant churches and
there's a whole other story
there and in any case they had this old
fat cat named smokey who was pretty cool
i liked smokey um but he was in kind of
rough shape and they just basically
dumped this this cat off with my
girlfriend and
she um she took him in and she really
you know did her best with him he got
sick after a while and had to be fed by
hand you know squirting food down his
throat but
he was also kind of lonely and so she
thought well i'll get this this kitten
and uh bring that and then they can hang
out together now you know smokey wasn't
too enthused to have a
several month old kitten running around
doing all the things that kittens do and
mew is really quite a handful i i
remember playing with her and you know i
would do the thing with have a feather
on a stick and she would jump and flip
in the air and smokey would just kind of
look at her but smokey came to like her
quite a bit
and then when smokey died mew was very
very
sad she was lonely she was she was upset
she wanted to have people around her all
the time but even then she was kind of
droopy now here's where monkey comes
into the story so i had those two
kittens who'd by that time become young
cats who i kept from the litter that
their mother had had brought into my
trailer one day and effectively just
left with me to to adopt
and little boy and little girl i would i
they had collars and i would let them
outside of the trailer on clothesline
leashes and
they didn't like other cats when other
cats would come around little boy and
little girl who were pretty tough little
things would team up little boy and
little girl both very big cats too
little boy ended up topping out at 25
pounds
later on in his life
this is before he got fat so he was just
all muscle and
pretty pretty gigantic and kind of scary
you know so most other cats would stay
out of my yard or they'd be chased out
of my yard
monkey was an exception
monkey would come around
and he was he was very
submissive very friendly he wanted to be
petted you could tell that he was
somebody's cat i should mention too that
one of the things that happens a lot in
places like you know carbondale is you
have all these students who came down
from chicago or other places upstate in
illinois and they adopt a puppy they
adopt a kitten and it's only while
they're there because when they head
back home they abandon it and so there
were lots of feral cats lots of feral
dogs running around sometimes they would
get adopted and monkey was clearly
a loving you know little thing he was he
was black except for a little tiny white
spot on his fur and he was um he wasn't
huge he wasn't little he was certainly
small next to a little boy he was about
the same size as little girl who as a
female was a bit smaller
and monkey would go up to them and they
would bump noses and they would rub
against each other and i was like wow
this is this is really quite cool
um i wonder should i take him in and so
around that time smokey died
and mew was you know getting very sad
and droopy and so i suggested to my
girlfriend i said why don't you why
don't you take monkey
and um he can you know become yours and
keep her company and so they did that
and
monkey and mew you know they had a
little bit of like you know
figuring out their boundaries and
borders and stuff like that mew is a
very dominant personality cat as it
turned out
and monkey um adapted as he did in every
condition now why did we call him monkey
we didn't know what his name was he
would make a little kind of chirping
noise like
and it sounded kind of like a monkey in
some respects so i just started calling
him monkey and he started responding to
it mew of course you know the name of
the the sound that she would make mew so
uh and it was spelled with kind of a
french spelling so now you've got monkey
and mew living with my girlfriend who
i'm spending you know plenty of time at
her place and loving the cats and stuff
like that
then we decide to move in together uh
when we get engaged and so we rent a
house and now all four cats are living
together little boy little girl monkey
mute took a bit of you know negotiating
on their parts and here's where it it
got quite interesting
mew was incredibly intelligent she was
also a bit neurotic as intelligent
people and intelligent animals can
sometimes tend to be
um she we used to joke that she had a
guilty conscience right
but she was also adventurous the way
that cats typically are and she she
figured out that the door handle had
something to do with opening the door
all the cats like to go outside all of
them you know wanted to do that and so
she would get up on the stove which was
right next to the door and we would
catch her she would have her little paws
around the door handle and she'd be
trying to turn it and sometimes she
could actually get it to turn but of
course she couldn't pull it and she
would you could tell she was getting
frustrated she knew that there was
something involved here we used to joke
that if she had you know thumbs that she
would probably have gotten herself out
and
this you know intelligence continued on
and the you know sort of dominance
continued on when we moved from
carbondale to
my family's land in indiana which was
idyllic for these cats because my family
had originally had a farm in indiana
when they lived in chicago and when i
say my family i mean my grandfather and
grandmother and all of his brothers and
sisters
and their spouses they had pooled their
money bought a farm out in rural indiana
and they would take the kids out there
in the summer sometimes for the entire
summer sometimes just on weekends to get
out of the city and so my mother's
generation their cousins all grew up out
there when they sold the farm uh three
of the brothers bought
uh pro actually five of the brothers
brought bought property three of them
built houses they're
in in kind of a complex and so there was
a lot of acreage there were fields there
were trails there were woods and then
these three houses so we moved into one
i bought it with my inheritance since my
mother had died and the idea was we were
gonna you know live there and um you
know i would work uh we'd we'd have
gardens and stuff like that and for the
cats it was pretty amazing
they could go and range all over the
place some of them were more interested
in that monkey especially loved to be
with me as i was doing yard work or
landscaping or you know cutting trees
down with my chainsaw and then cutting
them up into bits and splitting woods he
he would hang out with me a lot of the
time and by then uh you know my my young
my oldest daughter katherine
um
who's five years older than her younger
sister so for a while it was just
katherine catherine and i spent a lot of
time together doing stuff in the yard i
didn't let her around my chainsaw of
course that was just me but we would
stack wood and you know clear out parts
of of the overgrown
areas and blaze trails and all that and
monkey and her kitten carrie
who um was from astray who we took in
catherine got to keep one would hang out
with us a lot of the time as with little
boy sometimes little girl would
sometimes mew would but it was mostly
the boys who were interested in going on
little you know hikes with us and
trips and you know hanging out as we
we did things and they were really great
cats they also spent a lot of time
in the house they loved catherine um you
know i remember when when we brought her
home from the hospital
and each of the cats like you know she
was in a little baby seat each of the
cats came up and like sniffed her and
then like you know went away a little
bit and then sniffed her some more
monkey was a very very loving cat and
he actually you know they say that
tomcat shouldn't be allowed around
kittens because they'll try to kill him
monkey was the opposite monkey was the
awesome uncle
who would you know snuggle with and go
over by and play with and put up with
the kittens and when carrie was kept
monkey took him
almost like a little apprentice and this
is going to sound terrible but they were
a killing team monkey
knew how to hunt and he taught carrie
how to hunt and once that happened the
number of animals that they were killing
increased exponentially we'd find you
know little rabbits and mice and birds
often beheaded with you know some of the
guts eaten all around the yard and you
know this is them doing their their cat
thing and doing it together
carrie eventually got to be about the
size of monkey and it was interesting to
watch them monkey would go off and carry
would be trailing behind him like a
couple cat lengths you know just just
following him around
mew could get a little bit territorial
as i mentioned she was one of the
dominant cats we tried when she started
getting fat and little boys started
getting fat to put them on a diet which
actually resulted in the other cats not
getting enough food because little boy
and mew would go and steal the other
cat's food and keep them away so we
couldn't effectively do that but
they were you know
they were quite interesting that way i
remember one time when i had come back
i was you know moved down to
fayetteville because i had to take a job
down there and i would come back to my
family i remember laying on the bed in
the bedroom with little girl on one side
of me laying next to me and mew laying
on the other side
and they tended to get a little bit
jealous of
my attention and my affection mew didn't
do this with the other cats but she did
it with a little girl and little girl
certainly reciprocated and i remember
they'd poke their head up and look at
the other one and hiss and then come
back down where the other one could see
him now the other one poke her head up
and hiss right and uh i was worried
they're actually gonna get a fight into
a fight on top of me but they didn't
and um you know mew lived pretty long um
she
was was there after after the divorce
when i
um you know i was still in fayetteville
and i made a deliberate decision to we
shouldn't sell the house let you know my
ex-wife and kids live there so mew
stayed with them for quite a while but
she unfortunately died she had this
tendency to like push things the garage
door
would be we had an automatic garage door
and the garage door would come down and
it's pretty heavy and she liked to run
and scoot under it as it was coming down
and one day
she was getting older and slower and it
caught her
right on the spine
and broke her back and
she was in some pain for a while
unfortunately my ex should have put her
out of her misery proverbially
right away but instead it took her a
while to die and the kids got you know
to see that for for what it's worth
and it was pretty disconcerting for them
and that was the end of mew
monkey had died
several years earlier than that
he had had some health problems one time
we came back from a trip when we were
still in carbondale to find his back
legs not working so we took him
immediately to the vet and they
diagnosed something that's kind of rare
for not killing you a saddle thrombosis
gave him some aspirin and then he was he
was fine for a while
but he must have known that he was dying
because you know one winter night
um he just didn't come come back you
know we'd often let the cats if they
wanted to go outside we'd let them go
outside even if it was snowy because
sooner or later they'd be back at the
door and scratching and meowing and we'd
let them in well monkey didn't come back
and he didn't come back and he didn't
come back so catherine and i uh my
oldest daughter we got a flashlight we
got you know dressed up and we went
around the yard looking for him calling
for him and then we found the footprints
leading to the back stairs
and we found him underneath the back
stairs and he was dead and he was he was
like frozen
stiff so you know
a little bit of grieving and then the
next day we went out to dig his grave
and that's what we did
burying him
out in the area that catherine and i had
cleared not too far from the county line
road that we lived on
in a beautiful
area at that time that now it's all
overgrown because you know nobody's
taken care of it for
decades but back then um
it was a beautiful area and we we buried
him out there
right next to a stump so catherine could
easily go out there and find him you
know she was very attached to monkey
perhaps less so to to mew
and uh yeah that was that was the end of
those two and
you know um how long did we have them um
probably
about 10 years for for
monkey maybe a little bit less
certainly at least 10 years from you
long enough for them to live a full life
with us
and with the other cats they i will also
mention one other thing as i bring this
to a close
so i talked about a dog
my aunt bibian and uncle scott lived in
a house just across the driveway and
uncle scott was a big hunter so he um he
had a dog
uh a labrador named belle
who was just a little bit older than or
actually maybe a little bit younger than
catherine they were the same year
and bella they got her as a puppy and
it was interesting to see because when
you put
a number of cats together
you've got something like a pack right
they behave a bit differently when
they're a whole bunch of them
so belle grew up with these cats and
belle got bigger and bigger and bigger
and she always got along with them
but the cats would do something
that
really freaked her out they liked to
stalk her
and so you've got this giant 80-pound
dog right
a hunting dog and
sometimes they'd be like you know mew
and monkey and little boy sometimes
little girl would get in on the action
when carrie was around later he would do
it as well
and they'd all be like watching
belle who would be like you know a good
distance away
and one cat would start creeping forward
and maybe go like 10 feet and then just
stop and look at her and bell would be a
little bit nervous looking around what's
going on
another cat would creep up
and then another cat would creep up and
they'd get closer and closer and closer
to her you know until they were about
maybe five feet away and then she'd
freak out and start barking and you know
twisting around and then run away
these tiny cats
would effectively muscle a dog out of
her own territory but sometimes we would
also catch them like you know snoozing
together and they all they all liked
each other quite a bit
um so that's kind of a cool
story to end with and so this is my um
you know i think third
cat story at this point um there's more
to tell about other cats in my lifetime
but i just wanted to
introduce you to two of the cats that
were really important to me monkey and
mew
you